I was convicted of murder when I was a
young girl I have been an inmate for 15
long years there has been a crime people
want a guilty persons rightly or wrongly
does not matter you given up over being
set free I saved my hopes for smaller
matters
I live in hopes of having a better
breakfast tomorrow than I had today
I'm a doctor I'd work mind it is not a
question of your guilt or innocence that
concerns me I simply wish to know what
you yourself connect you amendment no
spark my memory entirely my hope sooner
or later we will bring back your memory
I'm not at all sure I want it back
when I close my eyes I can remember
every day to hell off that house the
same sort of work from dawn to dusk
always a mistress ordering me by if I
could is from this fool stupid strange
to reflect of all the people living in
our house I was the only one of them
left at ID in six months time have you
developed your own theories for
governing her sanity she could be a true
amnesiac
or simply guilty you are surrounded by
dangers here
grace said she heard that speak to her
[Music]
[Applause]
they thought you could find answers
it is knowledge of me you crave doctor
[Music]
knowledge of the lurid glare to
knowledge aimed through a descent into
the pit
you want to go where I can never go how
can I be a murderer
[Music]
you
you